هددت هذه الوثائق المسربة
بإلقاء الضوء مرة أخرى على
شبكة الصين المترامية الأطراف من معسكرات الاعتقال في
منطقة شينجيانغ الغربية البعيدة حيث
تقول وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية إن ما يصل إلى
مليوني أقلية مسلمة معظمهم من الأقليات
العرقية قد تم نشرها من قبل
الاتحاد الدولي
للصحفيين الاستقصائيين.
كشفت الوثائق الست التي يعود تاريخها إلى عام 2017 في الغالب عن
خطط لبناء عدد كبير من
المرافق الأمنية المشددة حيث
يُجبر السجناء على تعلم اللغة الصينية
وتلقي تعليم أيديولوجي غير مقتبس
لمدة عام على الأقل
لطالما أصرت بكين على هذه المعسكرات الضخمة أو
التدريب المهني التطوعي.  مراكز التدريب
حيث يمكن للطلاب القدوم والذهاب بحرية ،
لكن المعلومات والتفاصيل الواردة في هذه
الوثائق تتعارض مع هذه الادعاءات التي تظهر
المسؤولين يفرضون استخدام
كاميرات مراقبة للأبواب المغلقة وحراس على مدار 24 ساعة
مع وثيقة واحدة تؤكد
عدم السماح أبدًا بأي عمليات هروب لم تتمكن سي إن إن
من القيام بها بشكل مستقل.  التحقق من
الوثائق نحن  تواصلوا مع
حكومة منطقة شين جيانغ
للتعليق ، لكن يوم الاثنين
رد مسؤول بوزارة الخارجية الصينية بغضب على
الأخبار التي نشرها كوفيري لي ، بعض وسائل الإعلام
الحيل الخسيسة التي قالها لإثارة
القضايا المتعلقة بشين جاو
وتشويه مكافحة الإرهاب والتطرف في الصين.
الجهود في شينجيانغ محكوم عليها بالفشل.
إطلاق هذه
المعسكرات الضخمة في شينجيانغ قال النقاد
والمعتقلون السابقون دائمًا إن هذه المعسكرات
أقيمت للقضاء على لغة ويجر
وتراثها الثقافي ، لكن بكين
تصر على أن مراكز التدريب هذه جزء
من حملة التطرف في الإقليم الشمالي في
منطقة لها تاريخ من الاضطرابات
والعنف  بتحريض من
المتطرفين الإسلاميين ستيفن جونز سي إن إن بكين